donc mes chers collègues nous recevons
ce matin des représentants de la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo retransmis
en direct sur le site du Sénat et
ensuite à la demande
cette audition s'inscrit dans le cadre
des travaux que nous menons sur la fin
de vie
menée par nos rapporteurs Christine
bonfantidosa Corinne Imbert et Michel
meunier qui avaient déjà fait un rapport
en 2021 sur les soins palliatifs
et des auditions que nous avons menées
en plénière comme hier encore avec la
ministre Agnès Firmin loboto nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir madame Claire
Touri qui est président du comité de le
gouvernance de la convention citoyenne
et qui pourra nous éclairer sur la
manière dont celle-ci a conduit ses
travaux et quatre citoyens membres de la
Convention citoyenne
représentative de la diversité des
points de vue exprimés en son sein
madame Clotilde Audibert monsieur
Antonin de Bernard Madame Nathalie
Bériot et Monsieur Micha
Jovanovic c'est ça ça se prononce comme
ça
sera très bien c'est un peu ça fait très
joueur de tennis autrement en ce moment
pour ceux qui regardent Roland Garros
c'est non je ne regarder Roland Garros
que le week-end mesdames messieurs je
vous propose de commencer cette position
commune par un propos liminaire
relativement bref afin de laisser toute
leur place aux échanges qui suivront à
partir des rapporteurs et ensuite de
l'ensemble des sénateurs qui le
souhaiteront madame Toury je vous laisse
la parole
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
beaucoup de nous recevoir ce matin donc
moi j'ai eu le privilège de briser le
comité de gouvernance de cette
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
qui a commencé ses travaux le 9 décembre
et qui les a terminé le 3 avril donc
c'est 9 weekends dans tout 27 jours de
travail qui ont permis d'aboutir à la
production citoyenne dont vous allez
prendre connaissance peu de temps après
puisque les citoyens membres de la
Convention vous en diront quelques mots
alors comment ça s'est passé donc le
comité de gouvernance notre mission a
été de de fixer le cadre méthodologique
du travail de la convention de définir
les grands enfin de faire des grands
arbitrages et de définir le calendrier
de travail donc on a tout de suite
décidé d'avoir
185 citoyens alors pour être honnête
avec vous on avait décidé d'avoir plus
de citoyens que pour la convention
climat il y avait 150 citoyens à
l'époque nous on voulait qu'il y ait au
moins 150 citoyens aussi mais
contrairement à la Convention climat on
c'est que ceux qui terminent et
commencer et donc par peur de d'une
perte en ligne disons vu que c'est quand
même très très lourd on a décidé d'en
tirer au sort 170
l'organisme en charge du tirage au sort
nous a dit si vous en voulez 170 le 9
décembre il faut que vous en ayez 185 le
2 décembre et ben en fait il y en avait
185 de décembre 185 le 9 décembre et 184
à la fin ce qui
atteste
d'une d'une
merci
ce qui atteste quand même d'une volonté
très très forte de la part de ses
citoyens de ses citoyens de se saisir
d'une question difficile complexe et moi
je j'ai été là à chaque fois et je peux
vraiment
témoigner devant vous de la rigueur de
l'exigence de l'intelligence collective
donc c'est 184 citoyens on fait preuve
donc 194 citoyens
représentatif de la diversité de la
population française donc des hommes des
femmes des jeunes des moins jeunes
toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles tous les niveaux
de diplôme qui ont toutes les origines
géographiques qui ont travaillé sur une
question difficile à savoir je vous je
vous rappelle la question qui nous a été
posée par la première ministre le cadre
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie est-il
adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient-ils être introduit ça c'est la
question générale et donc pour organiser
la convention le la première ministre a
saisi le CESU donc le Conseil économique
social et environnemental dont je suis
membre et donc voilà donc c'est comme ça
que les travaux ont commencé alors sur
le déroulé je vous le disais c'est 9
weekends du vendredi au dimanche
en quatre mois donc c'est quand même
très très soutenu et puis vous le diront
mais le lundi est retourné au boulot
donc c'est vraiment un engagement très
très important de leur part 9 weekends
trois phases une première phase qu'on a
appelé appropriation et rencontre durant
laquelle les citoyens les citoyens ont
découvert le CESU ont découvert la
question posée par la première ministre
ce sont rencontrés ont échangé entre eux
on leur a aussi surtout dit pourquoi ils
étaient là et pourquoi ils n'étaient pas
là donc ça c'était très important
autrement dit il y a jamais eu
d'ambiguïté dans le cadre de cette
convention à aucun moment on a dit aux
citoyens qu'ils étaient là pour faire
une loi c'est pas la raison pour
laquelle ils ont été réunis en revanche
la conviction qu'on a au CESU et je
crois que cette convention le montre
bien c'est que pour certains sujets à
certains moments c'est important de
faire appel à des personnes qui ne
représentent que même une certaine
manière pour ressortir des espaces de
représentation d'intérêts classiques et
puis leur demander d'aider à construire
la décision qui sera bel et bien prise
par les gens ont été élus pour ça donc
les parlementaires le gouvernement etc
le président de l'Afrique le
gouvernement etc donc voilà donc il y a
pas il y a jamais eu d'ambiguïté
là-dessus pas de pas de sans filtre en
gros donc chacun son travail mais
l'enjeu c'était bien d'avoir une
contribution citoyenne à un débat
national sur la fin de vie qui a été
ouvert en septembre dernier si je dois
le marquer par une date par la vie du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique
qui pour la première fois ouvre la porte
à une éventuelle aide active à mourir
donc première phase appropriation et
rencontre sur deux weekends ensuite
deuxième phase de délibération pour
notamment poser la controverse donc
autour de la dactive à mourir notamment
mais les citoyens citoyennes et
reviendront sur ce point et puis une
troisième phase de
d'harmonisation et de restitution
puisque produire un texte à 184 c'est
quand même un exercice
difficile voilà mais ça il vous le
diront donc qu'est-ce qui nous a guidé
dans la conduite de ces travaux
[Musique]
le parti pris qu'on a eu tout de suite
en tant comité de gouvernance c'est de
se dire que le consensus n'était pas
comment dire n'était pas il n'était pas
impératif d'atteindre le consensus si
c'était le cas tant mieux mais si ce
n'était pas le cas tant pis et que sur
la question de la fin de vie il y avait
évidemment une partie qui était
transversale
s'il vous plaît merci et une partie qui
était transversale dont les citoyens
vous parleront ensuite et qui est plutôt
consensuel qu'on appelle le quoi qu'il
en soit mais il y a une partie de
controverse autour notamment de l'aide
active à mourir et donc l'enjeu a bien
été pour éclairer la décision publique
pour éclairer les décideurs vous
notamment et bien été de d'expliquer la
controverse autour de la question de la
dactive à mourir et donc de poser à la
fois les points de convergence mais
aussi les points de divergence sans
faire comme s'il n'existait pas et ça
c'est très important puisque dans la
réponse des citoyens la question de la
dactive à mourir 75% d'entre eux se sont
prononcés en faveur 25% d'entre eux se
sont prononcés contre mais il y a pas de
de rapport minoritaire il y a un seul
rapport une seule production de la
attention puisque on a bien voulu
produire un texte qui mettait en miroir
à la fois les arguments en faveur les
arguments en défaveur et puis surtout
montrer la complexité et la nuance même
si on dit qu'on est pour la dactive à
moi ça veut pas dire grand-chose en
réalité et c'est bien pour ça qu'on fait
une convention citoyenne et qu'on se
contente pas d'un sondage et qu'il faut
poser précisément ce que ça signifie les
critères enfin quelle forme quels
critères pour qui comment etc et là on
voit bien que vous avez pas uneanimité
évidemment
ni des positions évidentes donc voilà
nous c'est ce qui nous a semblé vraiment
essentiel c'est de revendiquer à la fois
la complexité de revendiquer la nuance
et de montrer que
même si la nuance existe ça n'empêche
pas d'aboutir à une majorité qui se
dégage sans alimenter ni les
polarisations ni les humiliations moi ce
qui m'a semblé important quand j'ai pris
la présidence de ce comité de
gouvernance je me suis dit bon il y
avait plein de raisons il y a plein de
choses que je me suis dit par ailleurs
sur ce comment je pourrais on pourrait
évaluer le succès au nom de cette
convention mais un des points qui me
semblait très important c'est qu'en
sortant ça il y a pas des humiliations
des polarisations des points de vue qui
ne se sent pas ni considérés ni
représenter et je vous donne je vous
partage cette anecdote parce qu'elle est
assez parlante le dernier
jour juste avant que les citoyens votent
leur livrables l'une d'entre eux a pris
la parole et qui était plutôt dans la
partie des minoritaires on va dire après
la parole et a dit voilà je voudrais
remercier les 75% d'entre vous d'avoir
laissé 20 à 25% d'entre nous 50% du
temps de parole et 50% de la place dans
le livrable et ça je trouve que c'est
quand même très important de de le
souligner parce que encore une fois et
après bon je répondrai à vos questions
mais encore une fois le l'exercice
démocratique auquel on a assisté pendant
ces quatre mois c'est un modèle vraiment
c'est absolument exemplaire beaucoup
d'écoute quand les gens interviennent il
y a une écoute quand même assez forte
une considération de tous les points de
vue ça aussi le souci de ne pas imposer
quelque chose sur la fin de vie c'est un
sujet qui est à la fois parfait pour une
convention mais en même temps qui peut
être pardonnez-moi l'expression mais
hyper casse gueule en fait et donc ça
n'a pas été le cas parce que il y a eu
vraiment ce souci de se respecter et de
ne pas dire à l'autre qu'il avait tort
et que la personne enfin il y a pas
certains n'ont pas tort et d'autres
n'ont pas raison c'est pas ça le sujet
le sujet c'est comment est-ce que
s'ennuyer les individualités sans y est
l'intime puisque c'est une question
évidemment intime on arrive à construire
un cadre collectif qui va pouvoir
éclairer la décision publique et
potentiellement faire chemiller la
société vers quelque chose de différent
a priori voilà pour mon propos liminaire
mais je
vous laisse poursuivre maintenant nous
allons vous laisser la parole vous dire
comment vous vous avez vécu cette
convention citoyenne
bonjour
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs donc le sujet de la fin de vie
a réuni comme la dit claire Toury 184
citoyens qui ont été tirés au sort pour
répondre à la question posée par madame
la Première ministre Elisabeth borne le
cadre de l'accompagnement de la fin de
vie est-il adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées ou d'éventuelles
changements devraient-elles
devraient-ils être introduit
pardonnez-moi c'est à cette question que
nous citoyens avons répondu lors de
débats approfondi et respectueux pour
construire justement du dialogue sur ce
sujet complexe qui touche à la fois à
l'intime et au collectif
la convention citoyenne qui nous a réuni
c'est un exercice de démocratie
participative qui permet de redonner la
parole aux citoyens dans le souci
d'enrichir le débat public améliorer la
qualité la légitimité des décisions et
ce afin de mieux répondre aux attentes
de la population donc pour accomplir ces
travaux et comprendre les enjeux qui en
sont liés nous avons rencontré un nombre
important de spécialistes du sujet
environ une soixantaine ce qui nous a
permis ensuite de débattre de manière
éclairée
le dialogue a permis d'esquisser des
perspectives des propositions communes
en prenant en compte le vécu et les
différentes sensibilités exprimées au
sein de la société française ces travaux
menés dans le cadre de la convention
citoyenne peuvent éclairer les pouvoirs
publics et nourrir la législation future
donc les citoyens ont répondu à 97% que
le cadre d'accompagnement de la fin de
vie doit être améliorée et à 82% qu'il
n'est pas adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées la conviction
commune est de renforcer d'améliorer
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie car à
ce jour on constate une inégalité
d'accès et une absence de réponse
satisfaisante pour certaines situations
de fin de vie
plusieurs propositions collectives ont
été adoptées à plus de
80%. le respect du choix et de la
volonté du patient l'information grand
public le renforcement de la formation
des professionnels de santé
garantir les budgets nécessaires et
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
développer l'accompagnement à domicile
garantir un accès aux soins palliatifs
pour tous et sur l'ensemble du
territoire
assuré une égalité d'accès et améliorer
l'organisation du parcours de soins de
la fin de vie
cette réflexion commune
issue de la démocratie participative a
mis en exergue la nécessité de
développer la culture palliative et les
soins palliatifs dans une société plus
solidaire tout en octroyant des droits à
ceux qui le demandent concernant leur
fin de vie notre travail à vocation à
alimenter la réflexion des pouvoirs
publics en esquissant des propositions
qui pourraient peut-être être le modèle
français de l'aide active à mourir je
laisse la parole à trois autres
conventionnelles Nathalie B Antonin Day
qui représentera le point de vue des
universalistes et Micha qui est opposé à
l'aide active à mourir je vous remercie
si vous pouvez avant qu'on continue
rappeler comment comment vous avez été
choisi
désigner
clairement de façon très précise très
bien je vais le faire si c'est ok pour
toi toi nous avons en fait été tiré au
sort à partir des numéros de téléphone
85% à partir des téléphones portables
15% à partir des téléphones fixes une
société nous a appelé il y a eu un
premier tour on va dire 3000 appels des
gens ont répondu ou pas enfin
imaginez-vous recevons à 20h un coup de
fil en général on pense qu'on veut nous
vendre des fenêtres donc il y a pas mal
de exactement donc il y a eu pas mal de
gens qui ont fait ça et donc ensuite il
y a eu 2000 personnes qui ont été qui
ont accepté et puis il y a eu un certain
nombre de critères qui étaient
nécessaires pour justement montrer la
diversité de la population évidemment le
genre l'âge la localisation géographique
les CSP
la le niveau d'études et puis il y en
avait un cinquième non c'était tout 5
pardon et ces cinq critères ont permis
ensuite à partir des 2000 de ressortir
citoyens et citoyennes
c'est moi
donc madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les membres de la commission
des affaires sociales je vais présenter
donc la partie aide active à mourir qui
a été le sujet central pendant les
débats de la convention citoyenne dans
le rapport que vous avez certainement
lui il y a un nuancier de trois opinions
qui a émergé pendant ces débats et je
vais donc vous brosser rapidement le
premier sur l'accès à l'aide active à
mourir sous conditions on verra qu'il y
en a un autre qui a un autre modèle la
convention citoyenne c'est positionnée
majoritairement à 75% en faveur de
l'aide active à mourir dans le rapport
vous pouvez aussi qu'il y a quatre
modèles des modèles avec du suicide
assisté et euthanasie au choix suicide
assister ou euthanasie par exception
suicide assister seul euthanasie seul le
modèle suicide assisté euthanasie au
choix et celui qui a remporté 40%
des suffrages je rappelle les principaux
arguments en faveur de l'aide active à
mourir que nous avons
mis dans le dans le rapport premièrement
un cadre d'accompagnement actuel qui ne
répond pas à certaines situations de
souffrance comme les situations de
souffrance réfractaires tant physique
que psychique pour ne prendre que cet
exemple de les soins palliatifs sont
complémentaires mais ne répondent pas
toutes les situations des personnes en
fin de vie même avec le développement
des soins palliatifs resteront ces
quelques personnes dans les souffrances
sont inapaisables et qui souhaitent en
être soulagés troisième point l'aide
d'activer à mourir vient combler les
limites de la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès qui vous le
savez ne peut s'appliquer que sur une
courbe période de la fin de vie car les
médicaments utilisés ont un effet limité
dans le temps or certaines agonies
durent plusieurs jours voire dépasse la
semaine ce sont ces patients donc
Conseil d'État parle quand il écrit
qu'il n'en finissent pas de mourir pour
lesquels nous pensons que les actives à
mourir pourrait être une solution les
natives à mourir réduit ce temps de
l'agonie sous l'agent celles et ceux qui
n'ont choisi la famille dans certaines
situations les soignants
autre point quatrième l'aide actif va
mourir mais fin aux situations
d'hypocrisie car l'euthanasie passive où
illégal quel que soit la façon qu'on la
nomme existe la mettre en oeuvre l'aide
d'activent à mourir c'est faire entrer
dans le droit à une réalité c'est éviter
l'hypocrisie et protéger le corps
médical cinquième point l'aide d'activer
à mourir respectent la liberté de choix
des individus en offrant la possibilité
de préparer sa mort dans un cadre
sécurisé et de pouvoir inclure ses
proches dans le processus de fin de vie
elle permet aux personnes de décider des
conditions de leur fin de vie et de
choisir l'état de l'image qu'elle
souhaite laisser d'elle-même à leur
entourage au moment de leur mort sixième
point l'aide active à mourir permet une
fin de vie accompagnée et est un gage de
fraternité de solidarité c'est un moment
choisi et un moment accompagné légaliser
la haine pourrait transformer notre
rapport à la mort car on organisant
soi-même son départ le deuil de ses
proches pourrait être vécu différemment
et mieux accepter cela permettrait
d'éviter également des suicides violents
c'est proposer une mort solidaire au
lieu d'une mort solitaire nos
propositions s'appuient sur des critères
d'éligibilité
sur lesquels nous pourrons revenir si
vous le souhaitez la majorité de la
convention citoyenne s'accorde sur la
nécessité d'un parcours d'accès à la M
incluant conditions d'accès garde-fous
et mécanismes de contrôle c'est très
important pour nous le préalable à tout
accès de l'aide d'active à mourir et
évidemment la volonté du patient qui
doit être respectée dans le droit fil de
la loi 2002 sur les droits des patients
les étapes de ce parcours d'accès à la
haine sont au nombre de 5 une expression
de la demande libre éclairée et
révocable à tout moment un
accompagnement médical et psychologique
complet une évaluation du discernement
une validation de l'entrée de dans le
parcours d'aide active à mourir soumise
à une procédure collégiale et
pluridisciplinaire une réalisation de
l'acte encadré par le corps médical
l'aide médicale à mourir et la
contrepartie de notre médecine puissante
et comme le rappelle le professeur
régisse Aubry soigné n'est pas imposé
ses convictions mais respecter celles
des autres je conclurai en disant que le
dispositif convention citoyenne je
répondrai votre question de tout à
l'heure madame la Présidente et pour moi
vraiment un dispositif absolument
formidable au service de la démocratie
l'utiliser localement au niveau des
régions ou nationalement sera un moyen
de redonner de la confiance dans nos
institutions en intég rant concrètement
les citoyens et les citoyens dans les
processus délibératifs merci de votre
attention
continuez est-ce que dans ce panel il y
avait des personnes qui qui
appartiennent à l'Association pour le
droit de mourir d'indemnité
alors c'était pas un critère et en fait
sur les critères qui ont été posés comme
le disait Nathalie c'est vraiment des
critères de base en vraiment pour avoir
une forme de diversité de la population
française on a choisi on a choisi de
Next cœur ni les patients ni par mon ni
les soignant ni les personnes
confrontées à une situation de fin de
vie récente ni les militants voilà après
sur le sur le le collectif il y a
personne qui s'est présenté comme un
militant de la l'association pour droit
à mourir dans la dignité ni comme un
militant d'une association contre contre
la dactive à mourir c'est pas voilà
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat nous venons d'entendre
la présentation de la première option
des dactyls à mourir qui est
conditionnée à un certain nombre de
critères je représente aujourd'hui le
groupe d'opinions des universalistes
pour nous le libre arbitre du sujet à
disposer de lui-même et ce qui fait foi
en effet la volonté de la personne doit
être respectée et elle prime quoi qu'il
arrive nous prenons un accès universel à
l'aide activa mourir il s'agit d'ouvrir
le suicide assisté et le tanazie à toute
personne exprimant la volonté de ne plus
vivre et démontrant un discernement
direct et continue dans notre approche
toute demande d'aide active à mourir
déclenche un parcours
d'accompagnement spécifique et
individualisé adapté à la temporalité de
la situation et dont la vie est
consultatif
ce parcours pluridisciplinaire intègre
de nombreuses étapes qui constituent
autant de garde-fous permettant
d'encadrer l'accès à l'aide active à
mourir la personne peut se rétracter à
tout moment à chaque étape du parcours
le caractère révocable de la demande
doit être rappelé de façon neutre et
sans volonté d'influencer la personne
les solutions médicales thérapeutiques
ou sociales qui lui seront proposés lui
permettent d'avoir un réel
accompagnement et suivi dans un système
de santé bien trop souvent inégalitaire
voire inaccessible ce car ce parcours
pardon permet aussi de désaxer le
patient de ce choix en lui offrant
d'autres solutions et alternatives une
procédure de contrôle et de traçabilité
et déployée durant tout le parcours par
ailleurs cette approche s'accompagne
d'une clause de conscience pour les
professionnels de la santé
dans le cas d'une perte ou d'une absence
de discernement la personne sera soumise
à une procédure collégiale
plurisciplinaire d'exception spécifique
et initié par le biais des directives
anticipées de la personne de confiance
ou d'une demande des proches l'ouverture
de l'euthanasie pourra alors être
envisagée
dans le cas d'un désaccord entre un
mineur personne en curatelle ou tutelle
et les parents un juge approprié statut
comprenez que c'est l'approche d'une
ouverture d'elle active à mourir la
moins discriminante à nos yeux en effet
nous permettons ainsi d'assurer une
égalité d'accès à l'aide activement
mourir sans considération médicale
sociale financière ou territoriale
chaque personne peut demander une aide
active à mourir nous replaçons le
souffrant au cœur des considérations
sociales en faisant ainsi vivre
pleinement le principe de solidarité ce
que nous craignons c'est un système qui
abandonne les personnes à mi-chemin que
certains aient le droit de ne plus
souffrir mais que d'autres soient
confrontés à cela sans aucune porte de
sortie il y a déjà des oubliés dans le
système actuel nous le souhaitons pas
qu'il y en ait davantage dans
l'ouverture de ce nouveau droit
le fait que ce choix soit possible
permet d'avoir une solution sans devoir
forcément aller jusqu'au bout du
processus ce n'est pas parce que l'on
propose que l'on impose cependant cette
ouverture ne doit pas empêcher
d'augmenter les moyens globaux alloués
au système de santé notamment pour les
soins palliatifs la viabilité de cette
approche est évidemment conditionnée à
l'occasion d'un budget suffisant pour
son application pleine et entière ce
droit universel garantit une liberté à
tous sans entraîner la moindre
obligation ce droit universel n'entame
pas le contrat social mais donne
simplement un choix complémentaire aux
personnes en souffrance dans un souci de
fraternité ce droit universel permet de
répondre à toutes les situations
rencontrées dans un esprit d'égalité
charmant de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat merci de votre
attention
mesdames messieurs bonjour donc je
représente les citoyens de la convention
qui se sont positionnés contre
l'évolution de la loi et l'ouverture à
l'aide active à mourir
on est un groupe assez important dans le
sein de la Commission dans la convention
pardon et on entend ici non pas défendre
le livrable mais l'expliquer vous avez
entendu des chiffres ces chiffres là
sont à interpréter et à comprendre
par exemple dans les 75 % de gens qui
sont pour l'ouverture à l'aide activa
mourir il y a des gens qui sont opposés
à l'euthanasie d'autres qui sont opposés
au suicide assisté et en réalité le
socle de ceux qui sont pour l'aide
active à mourir et le chiffre qui a été
dit par ma camarade 40% qui sont pour
l'ouverture
complète et à l'euthanasie et au succès
d'assister donc les chiffres sont à
relativiser à expliquer les citoyens qui
se sont positionnés contre l'ont fait
pour des motifs très divers
d'une part parce que le modèle de
civilisation
qui consistait jusque là soigner coûte
que coûte à prendre soin du patient du
malade de la personne en souffrance
risque de changer pour un modèle vers
lequel on irait vers une médecine
libérale d'un libéralisme d'opinion
finalement chacun pourrait demander à la
carte ce qui l'arrangerait et ça nous
paraît inquiétant
par ailleurs
nous n'avons pas été convaincus par la
mise en place et l'explication des
garde-fous des commissions d'enquête qui
sont censées encadrer les processus de
tanasie ou de suicide assisté
et enfin nous nous avons considéré et je
pense à raison que le centre des débats
n'était pas sur le tanazing ou le
suicide assisté mais sur la question de
l'hôpital de sa gestion des soins
palliatifs et de l'accompagnement des
patients il y a beaucoup pas faire dans
ces domaines et les améliorations que
nous pourrions apporter à l'hôpital à sa
gestion aux soins sont un préalable à
tout autre discussion à mon avis
commencez par les questions des
rapporteurs ensuite
chez Laurence Cohen qui s'est inscrite
Christine Bonfanti de ça
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
donc à vous 5 pour le travail qui a été
défectué finalement je me rends compte
que cette week-end plein on a 9 pardon
on a l'impression que nous les
parlementaires finalement on ne fait pas
grand chose donc je salue je salue votre
travail alors moi j'ai plusieurs
questions à vous poser
la société me semble-t-il
modifie un peu son approche et ses
convictions influencer par l'évolution
de certaines pratiques observées par
certains pays et surtout certains pays
limitrophes est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que c'est à cause de ça largement
reprise par les médias voilà est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que c'est cela qu'il
peut entraîner une loi sociétale
progressiste
ensuite madame vous avez parlé plusieurs
fois d'hypocrisie comment peut-on parler
d'hypocrisie alors que 24% de des
citoyens a parlé de la méconnaissance et
de la faible application de la loi
classe néonetti ensuite
vous parlez madame aussi d'une morceau
libère et non d'une mort non du morceau
libère et non d'une mort solitaire
est-ce que vous considérez que le
l'euthanasie est un souhait et puis pour
une réflexion beaucoup plus personnelle
moi j'ai l'impression en lisant tous vos
travaux que d'un côté il y a les
progressistes et de notre côté des
conservateurs et ça ça me gêne
on va prendre toutes les questions des
rapporteurs Corinne Imbert ou Michel
meunier
merci madame la Présidente je pensais
que c'était Corinne Humbert puis Michel
meunier merci
Madame et Messieurs moi je n'ai peu de
questions sur le fond puisque je me sens
proche de vos
de vos de vos réflexions et du résultat
de votre travail il y a une question qui
m'étonne quand même c'est je vous sens
très organisé très rigoureux rigoureuse
dans la manière dont vous nous rendez
compte et de ce que j'ai entendu dans
vos travaux et vos 9 weekends de travail
qui organisait tout cela qui
concrètement a pris la plume pour
rédiger le rapport final est-ce les
cadres du 16h ou d'autres personnes donc
je voulais savoir comment est-ce que
vous vous étiez organisé autrement que
par votre propre discipline personnelle
parce que au fond vous ne vous
connaissiez pas si j'ai bien compris
donc c'est remarquable en tout cas ça me
pose question et puis peut-être une
question sur le fond est-ce que les
exemples autour de la France
européen de législation vous ont à un
moment donné
fourni des exemples donner des idées
poser des réflexions enfin voilà quelle
est la place des pays autour de la
France qui législation différente
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames merci messieurs
[Musique]
est-ce que rétrospectivement la question
qui vous a été posée vous semblait bien
posée
la loi la loi Paris hypothèse n'est pas
adaptée à toutes les situations nous le
savons
et donc une façon la façon dont est posé
la loi d'inciter de toute façon à aller
plus loin
comment ont été appréhendés par la
Convention les notions de droit et de
progrès
ensuite et Monsieur de Bernard vous
l'avez évoqué
pourrait être demandé via une personne
de confiance et je parle pas d'une
personne qui a rédigé ces directives
ça veut dire que quelqu'un pourrait
demander le Tani en tout cas la mort à
une perte pour une personne qui ne l'a
pas demandé comment ont lieu les débats
sur ce sujet là et puis enfin une
question de forme
une question de forme parce que Madame
Toury vous êtes à la fois vous avez
présidé cette convention citoyenne et
vous êtes membre du 16e
j'ai relu avec attention le courrier de
la première ministre
qui demandait aux ses œufs de veiller à
ce que la gouvernance de ces travaux
illustre les principes d'équilibre et de
neutralité indispensables à l'expression
de sa méthode je cite le courrier de la
première ministre le CESU avait émis un
avis en 2018 se prononçant favorablement
à la légalisation du système
l'euthanasie
comment pouvez nous expliquer en tant
que membre du CESU que le CESU a eu
besoin de présenter un nouvel avis après
la présentation des travaux de la
convention citoyenne je vous remercie
alors voilà les questions des
rapporteurs je vous laisse répondre
peut-être dans l'ordre comme ça
c'est pour ceux qui veulent répondre
madame Touré je vous laisse commencer et
puis ensuite on prendra des questions de
nos collègues
je vais vous répondre tout de suite sur
ce point là donc le comité de
gouvernance qui a qui a
été en charge de l'organisation des
travaux était composé de 14 personnes si
membre du CESU 8 personnalités
extérieures Simon du CESU je vous
expliquerai après comment ils ont été
choisis 8 personnalités extérieures dont
le président du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique Jean-François
delfrecy dont François Stas un
conseiller d'État à la retraite membre
du CCNE aussi dont la directrice du
Centre national des soins palliatifs et
de la fin de vie
Cynthia Fleury spécialisé question
d'éthique de chercheuses en charge des
questions de participation citoyenne
pour la méthode justement donc Hélène
landemort et Sandrine Ruy et deux
anciens citoyens de la convention climat
pour justement aider les décisions en
tant que ancien citoyen qui avait vécu
une expérience de participation
démocratique de ce type parmi les
critères qui ont conditionné le choix de
la présidence de ce comité de
gouvernance il y a justement le fait de
n'avoir jamais pris position sur le
sujet de la fin de vie publiquement ni
en tant que personne ni en tant que
représentant d'une organisation et c'est
important parce que le président du CESU
par exemple aurait pu présider le comité
de gouvernance mais lui justement dans
d'autres fonctions passées il avait pris
position et par souci de ne pas
contester le la légis enfin pas la
légitimité mais le l'exemplarité du
travail il a préféré se déporter et donc
moi je n'ai jamais jamais absolument
jamais pris position sur le sujet et le
CESU en 2018 quand il s'est quand il a
il a voter son avis c'était dans le
cadre d'une autre mandature avec
d'autres conseillers pour ce qui est du
fait d'avoir rendu un autre avis la
récemment vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que une loi a réformé le 16e la loi du
mois de janvier 2021 qui dit que donc le
CESU est désormais en plus d'être la
chambre de la société civile organisée
le carrefour de la participation des
publics et donc la chambre qui va être
chargée d'organiser les dispositifs
notamment de participation citoyenne
comme ça a été le cas pour cette
convention fin de vie mais ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel dit c'est que
ces travaux doivent être aussi attachés
à des travaux du CESU et donc du coup le
la décision collective qui a été prise
ça a été de dire voilà il y a un débat
national sur la fin de vie qui a été
ouvert comme je le disais par la vie du
comité d'éthique en septembre 2022 ce
débat national il a plusieurs
contributeurs
le comité d'éthique les sages les
soignants qui travaillent aussi enfin
vous avez entendu Agnès sûrement le
Baudot hier qui vous a aussi expliqué
comment elle elle avait travaillé donc
les soignants les associations etc il y
a eu plusieurs contributions il y a une
contribution centrale qui est celle de
la convention citoyenne puisque c'est la
contribution citoyenne mais il y a aussi
la contribution de la société civile
organisée qui s'est manifesté via la vie
du CESU dans le cadre de ce débat
national large qui a été rouvert au mois
de septembre donc voilà comment ça s'est
organisé pour vous répondre sur la
partie plus méthodologique et puis
ensuite sur le reste donc sur le fond je
laisserai je vous laisserai répondre
bien sûr mais peut-être juste un point
madame sur l'histoire des progressistes
et des conservateurs alors je sais pas
si c'est écrit comme ça dans un dans le
document mais voilà moi il me semble pas
qu'il y a aucun moment ce mot était
employé au contraire parce que de notre
part en tout
ah d'accord ok pardon d'accord alors
j'insiste là-dessus parce que nous notre
souci justement a été vraiment à chaque
fois de dire encore une fois il s'agit
pas de dire que certains ont tort et que
d'autres ont raison c'est vraiment pas
le sujet sur la fin de vie franchement
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un vienne
donner une leçon à quelqu'un d'autre en
lui expliquant que voilà lancer mieux
que l'autre je crois que c'est pas c'est
pas ça le ça n'a jamais été pensé ni
organiser comme ça et au contraire tout
le travail a été organisé de sorte à ce
que tous les points de vue puissent être
entendus enfin vous avez entendu ce
matin trois positions différentes qui
n'en 3 pour le coup bah il y a une
différence significative entre une aide
une
aide active à mourir avec des conditions
très claires et et des conditions voilà
enfin je pense que c'est vraiment une
différence assez notable donc vous avez
trois points de vie différents qui ont
été posés qui sont représentatifs de ce
que certains membres de la Convention
ont porté et dans le livrable vous avez
tous ces points de qui sont posés avec
un niveau de nuances qui va quand même
très très long je crois pour une
production de ce type voilà pour le la
méthode
plume qui a tenu la plume certaines
questions de Michel meunier
c'est ça
alors le il y a une première version en
fait il y a eu des productions qui ont
été faites au fil de l'eau tous les
weekends quasiment hormis les deux
premiers week-end qui étaient des
séquences plus d'audition mais tous les
week-ends
parce que oui pardon c'est vrai qu'on
vous a pas dit ça il y a un groupe de
184 citoyens c'est un grand groupe mais
après les travaux ils ont surtout eu
lieu en plus petit groupe vous vous en
doutez produire à 184 c'est quand même
compliqué donc il y avait des groupes de
10 puis des groupes de 30 qui ont été
amenés à débattre produire des des
réponses des questions etc enfin c'est
ça c'est fait en plusieurs étapes et
donc le collectif d'animation Les les
organes enfin celles-ci qui était en
charge de l'animation des travaux donc
pas le comité de gouvernance en 6
là-dessus on rédigé un document
martyr voilà qui a ensuite été repris
par les citoyens et donc à un moment on
est allé vraiment le plus loin possible
dans le le la production citoyenne
puisqu'on a découpé le document en je
sais plus combien de parties puis après
vous il y avait entre 7 et 10 citoyens
qui étaient en charge de chacune des
parties donc la rédaction et puis je
sais pas si vous êtes déjà allé au CESU
mais il y a une très grande salle qui ce
qu'on appelle la salle hip hostile aux
ses œufs avec les grandes colonnes je
décris pour celles et ceux qui nous
regardent mais voilà une très grande
salle et dans cette grande salle tous
les textes ont été affichés il y a eu un
grand moment de déambulation lors des
deux derniers weekends pour que les
citoyens puissent venir modifier le
texte et à chaque fois chaque partie
était
piloté on va dire par des rapporteurs
citoyens qui avaient été désignés par le
groupe et qui était chargé justement de
récupérer les suggestions des uns et des
autres de sorte à ce qu'à la fin il y a
quelque chose qui soit le plus
collectif et contributif possible en
sachant que voilà ça c'est un document
qui fait combien de pages je sais plus
170 pages donc c'est pas
184 personnes qui ont écrit en se tenant
la main les 194 pages évidemment vous
vous en doutez mais en tout cas tout a
été revu enfin tout a été produit revu
par les citoyens
c'est les citoyens
alors qui veut répondre à d'autres
questions qui ont été posées madame
Audibert alors je vais répondre sur la
question de l'influence des pays
limitrophes et les différents exemples
européens qui pourraient nous inspirer
également effectivement nous avons
auditionner différents représentants le
il y a eu la Belgique ou le tanasie
dépénalisé il y a la Suisse également on
a entendu le Québec et l'Orégon donc ça
nous a permis un petit peu de prendre
connaissance de ce qui se passait dans
les différents pays qui soit limitrophes
ou plus éloignées et
voilà ce qu'on s'est dit c'est que nous
nous copierons pas un modèle et qu'on
ferait par contre notre propre modèle
français voilà on regarde on observe ce
qui se passe dans les différents pays
mais nous déciderons parce que nous
sommes différents voilà
bien monsieur de Bernard ensuite madame
Bériot et monsieur
je vais reprendre la phrase donc j'ai lu
tout à l'heure par ailleurs dans le cas
d'une perte ou d'une absence de
discernement l'ouverture de l'euthanasie
pourra être envisagée elle sera alors
soumise à une procédure collégiale
spécifique et initié par le biais des
directives anticipées de la personne de
confiance ou d'une demande des proches
dans le cas où une directive anticipée
n'a pas été rédigée en effet nous nous
retrouvons dans une situation où vous
pouvez avoir une personne en mort
cérébrale une personne avec un
discernement qui s'en va avec une
maladie dégénérative par exemple et nous
sommes confrontés à quelque chose de
très complexe on est d'accord donc on a
beaucoup penché là dessus et les
universels comme les conditionnés nous
retrouvons quand même bien sur ce
point-là en fait
si il y a pas de dire direction anticipé
pardon mais une personne de confiance
comme dans le cadre actuel la personne
de confiance on lui fait confiance donc
on lui donne en amont l'idée de notre
fin de vie c'est à dire si un jour je
j'ai un accident de voiture que je me
retrouve en Nord cérébrale je ne veux
pas continuer à vivre si quelqu'un qui a
par exemple Alzheimer qui dit le jour où
je ne reconnais plus mes enfants je veux
partir il faut prendre tout cela en
considération je suis désolé je le mets
en avant ça c'est la personne le sujet
le patient qui décide
par la suite je tiens à vous préciser
que cela est toujours soumis à un
collège d'exception spécifique qui est
initié par ces directives anticipées si
elles ne sont pas là par la personne de
confiance ou par les proches nous
pouvons être en avant que nous nous
plaçons si face à la législation
actuelle où il ne doit pas y avoir
d'acharnement thérapeutique premièrement
donc quelqu'un mort cérébral qu'on
continue à faire vivre au final il y a
cet acharnement là donc nous nous
plaçons aussi face à cette législation
et tout cela en fait ce place sous la
confiance qu'on a amené en d'autres
personnes en revanche effectivement
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de proche qui n'a
pas de personne de confiance pas de
direction anticipée nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation très complexe et là
c'est aussi à la justice de trancher
pour la partie 11 discernement pour la
partie
justement de personnes en mort céréales
là il faut aussi faire confiance à la
justice il faut faire confiance à des
médecins il faut faire confiance à des
psychiatres accompagner la famille
auditionner tout le monde et c'est comme
ça qu'on pourra trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes rencontrées mais comme on
en a déjà trouvé dans des cas comme
Vincent Lambert et ça nous sommes déjà
retrouvés confrontés à cela
merci madame la Présidente je rajoute
qu'on a aussi entendu les Pays-Bas par
rapport à la liste des personnes et que
c'est sûr que ce qui se passe autour de
la France impact évidemment la France et
qui me semble que là on en est à la
deuxième convention citoyenne sur ce
sujet quand même pas dans les mêmes
formats mais qui avait conclu à la même
chose et que on a pas mal de sondages
encore une fois des citoyens qui disent
que il faut faire évoluer cette
situation qui est pose problème pour un
certain nombre de personnes sur
l'hypocrisie alors le lien avec la loi
claess Leonetti c'est sûr qu'il y a 24%
des citoyens qui connaissent pas la loi
ça on est bien d'accord il y a des
médecins on l'a vu on a vu aussi qu'il y
avait plein de gens qui ne savaient pas
ce qui était des directives anticipées
ce qui ne savait pas ce que ce qui était
la personne de confiance qui pense que
quand on va à l'hôpital et qu'on donne
le nom de quelqu'un c'est sa personne de
confiance on sait bien que c'est pas ça
mais en fait je crois que c'est pas
vraiment le problème quand moi je peux
je passais je vais penser aux jeux
conseille pas je mais mes collègues
conditionnés moi-même nous parlons de
enfin du fait qu'il y a des euthanasies
et qui a une hypocrisie
c'est que de fait contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu entendre lors de l'audition des
fédérations les sociétés savantes que
vous avez reçues nous en 4 mois on a
entendu pas mal de gens qui nous ont dit
d'autres témoignages donc vraiment qui
disaient que il y avait des euthanasies
qui ne portent pas ce nom là donc je
pense qu'on peut faire comme si ça
n'était pas le cas mais de fait il y a
en France des euthanasies et même la loi
aujourd'hui que les onetine ne permet
pas pour un certain nombre de raisons de
résoudre tous ces problèmes donc on nous
sommes peut-être que nous ne l'avons pas
dit assez clairement évidemment tous au
sein de la convention pour que il y ait
un gros travail de communication pour
que le Conseil national des soins
palliatifs et fin de vie prennent
vraiment encore plus de l'ampleur et
soit vraiment l'opérateur de cela pour
que la loi soit connue mais de fait
aujourd'hui
des médecins OK
sur mort solidaire est-ce que
l'euthanasie est un soin alors oui c'est
terrible je sais bien je pense je pense
que hélas oui aujourd'hui la médecine
permet de vivre longtemps aujourd'hui je
pense que personne ici ne peut dire
qu'ils mourra de morts naturels parce
que nous avons tous eu des opérations
nous avons tous eu des médicaments où
nous en avons aujourd'hui la mort
naturelle dans nos sociétés ça n'existe
plus en revanche ce qui existe c'est des
sites en tout cas pas beaucoup et en
revanche ce qui existe c'est des
situations ou des personnes vont avoir
des polypes pathologies vont être
maintenues parce qu'on a une médecine
absolument fabuleuse avec des médecins
hyper compétents qui permettent vraiment
de nous permettre d'avancer beaucoup
plus loin mais ça nous semble vraiment
important de permettre à des personnes
qui seraient dans des situations de
souffrance inapaisables parce que ça
existe que que ces personnes puissent
accéder à un moyen d'aide activement
monsieur Braun répond ce qu'il veut nous
conventions citoyenne répondons
absolument voilà mais il est dans son
rôle c'est ce que nous en dire les
médecins qui pratiquent l'euthanasie en
Belgique pour eux en effet c'était le
soin jusqu'au bout après on peut être
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord très bien
monsieur
Jovanovic
je vais répondre à plusieurs questions
dans l'ordre le modèle étranger le
modèle suisse moi il se trouve que
j'habite en Haute-Savoie et j'ai pu
interroger un médecin des soins
palliatifs de ma région qui auparavant
travaillant en Suisse et retourner
travailler en France dans des soins
palliatifs après son expérience Suisse
et avec un préjudice financier que vous
imaginez mais elle ne regrette pas une
seconde son choix sa décision de
travailler avec des patients en fin de
vie et de faire ce travail
d'accompagnement elle m'a même dit les
larmes aux yeux que c'était la chose la
plus enrichissante et la plus incroyable
qu'elle a eu de sa carrière et donc
la fin de vie peut être difficile les
l'idée de de soit anticiper de personnes
de confiance qu'on aurait donné à un
tenter ou notre discernement aurait été
telle le discernement change et puis
vous savez que
il peut être manipulé il peut être hyper
influencé la notion de discernement me
paraît un mauvais critère pour décider
du destin
d'un être humain
non c'est un choix de société un choix
de vie qui doit s'imposer à la société
et non pas le discernement privé
ça c'était pour le modèle suisse qui est
pas qui nous qui a effrayé je dois dire
plus qui a effray beaucoup de citoyens
de la Convention et qui justement pour
ça ce sont positionnés contre
parce que c'est c'est le modèle suisse
c'est un peu le une cérémonie une mise
en spectacle assez morbide qui fait peur
c'est pas
ensuite ça c'est pour le suicide pardon
pas pour l'euthanasie
pour ce qui est de la question de Madame
madame Humbert sur la formulation de la
de Madame le Premier ministre
oui alors on n'a pas eu le loisir de
d'examiner les présupposés de cette
question une question qui est orientée
puisque à la question est-ce que la loi
actuelle est-elle
était le suffisante la réponse naturelle
est non est-ce que vous connaissez une
loi qui s'applique parfaitement et qui
est parfaitement conforme à son objet et
qui répond à tous les cas il y a toutes
les situations évidemment non dans le
cadre actuel voilà évidemment les lois
ont vocation évolué et le la carte n'est
pas le territoire donc une loi s'est
évolutive beaucoup de citoyens qui
étaient contre ce sont prononcés pour
l'évolution de la loi
donc le les chiffres les chiffres
importants de citoyens qui voulait que
la loi évolue parmi ceux-ci il y a des
gens qui ne veulent pas ni d'euthanasie
ni de suicide assisté
donc effectivement on aurait on aurait
eu intérêt lors de la convention à
prendre plus de temps à analyser la
question de Madame le Premier ministre
il est dommage qu'on ne l'est pas fait
et on a rapidement été orienté sur la
question euthanasie suicide assisté et
je crois que c'est par moult combat
qu'on est revenu sur la question des
soins palliatifs
bon on va continuer les questions si
vous voulez bien et puis ensuite vous
vous en fonction des questions posées
chacun pourra répondre donner donner
formuler des observations et ce sera en
terminera ce tour de table alors
Laurence Cohen
oui mais merci madame la Présidente
merci messieurs et mesdames moi je veux
franchement vous remercier pour le
travail que vous avez fait et pour
la façon dont vous vous êtes organisé et
puisqu'on ressentent qu'à ce que moi je
ressens parce que évidemment c'est
subjectif c'est un grand respect des
points de vue de chacun et une écoute et
c'est à salué parce que c'est un sujet
difficile on l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises ici y compris on peut être
suivant les rencontres suivant les
auditions un peu ébranlées dans les
positions qu'on peut prendre à un moment
donné donc effectivement il faut que
chacun chacune reste humble et c'est en
tout cas moi ce que je ressens et en
tant que législateur triste je pense que
c'est bien d'avoir
l'opportunité de vous rencontrer
hier effectivement on a eu aussi
l'audition de la ministre Agnès Firmin
le Bodo et elle elle a parler de de
trois de trois volets extrêmement
importants qui tenaient à cœur au
gouvernement le développement des soins
palliatifs je vais vite l'ouverture d'un
nouveau droit donc l'aide active à
mourir et la protection des personnes et
du droit des personnes alors
effectivement
je pense que c'est une bonne façon de de
prendre cette question et vous l'avez
vous l'avez développé moi il me semble
qu'il faut pas il faut vraiment pas
lâcher vous n'avez pas lâché la question
des soins palliatifs a vraiment
développer parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une inégalité entre les départements
entre les territoires donc entre les
personnes et je crois qu'il l'une
d'entre vous l'a dit on peut pas non
plus décorréler à l'état actuel de notre
système de santé et des hôpitaux qui
avec la meilleure volonté du monde
manque de personnel donc de moyens
financiers humains donc tout ça c'est
effectivement à mettre en lien je pense
aussi que c'est pourtant de dire que
c'est une réflexion qui n'est pas qui
doit être aussi une réflexion de pas
privée mais de la société tout entière
et et moi ce qui me disons me tient à
coeur dans la façon de dire qu'il faut
revisiter la loi avec toute tous les
garde-fous parce qu'il peut y avoir des
dérives et on le sait pertinemment c'est
le fait qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas il y
a une grande inégalité parce que les
gens qui ont les moyens financiers de le
faire qui ont une famille qui peut les
accompagner et bien ont accès à
l'euthanasie ou à l'aide active à mourir
enfin le suicide assisté pardon le
suicide assisté et ça je trouve que on
ne peut pas faire comme si ça n'existait
pas on peut continuer à dire mais non
parce qu'il va y avoir des dérives etc
c'est vrai que mais vous l'avez dit
toute loi peut-être des voyelles il y a
jamais quelque chose de de parfait mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui de ces
inégalités inégalités qui pour moi est
une inégalité sociale et je trouve que
on doit être interpellé par le sujet et
faire en sorte justement de penser à
tout le monde tout le monde doit être
égal et moi c'est la grosse question qui
me tient à cœur
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente merci à tous
pour de la convention citoyenne pour
l'explication de vos travaux donc la
convention citoyenne a fait connaître
effectivement les soins palliatifs il y
en a qui connaissaient pas et notamment
dans certains départements il y a des
lits qui sont
qui sont initiés soins palliatifs et
d'autres alors qu'il y a pas d'unité de
soins palliative mais ça fonctionne
quand même très bien
je voudrais rappeler que
si vous voulez en Hollande vous n'avez
pas cité la Hollande je vais la cité 90%
de personnes
atteintes de maladies très graves avec
pronostic de décès à brève échéance et
bien il y en avait 90% en 2002 qui avait
subi une euthanasie donc là ça faisait
1800 et en 2018 et il y en a 7000 avec
seulement 61% qui était en fin de vie et
donc il est indiqué que si les soins
palliatifs avaient été existé en
Hollande et bien ignorer pas eu de
d'aide à mourir et donc je voulais donc
vous demander dans ma première question
si vous voulez
comment et bien quelle barrière
supplémentaire par rapport à ce pays
allez vous mettre en oeuvre pour que
cette dérive ne se produise pas en
France deuxièmement la loi léonétique
laisse c'est une sédation profonde et
continue présente dans nos départements
et donnant tiers satisfaction par contre
effectivement vous l'avez dit et je
pense qu'il faut
accompagnement sûrement à améliorer par
davantage de personnels le renforcer oui
les soins palliatifs pour tous tout à
fait oui je voudrais rappeler que
lorsque les personnes sont malades et
bien elles peuvent changer
si elles deviennent des menthes elles
peuvent changer complètement par rapport
au directives anticipées disons
l'immense majorité des malades lorsque
ça se dégrade et bien elles veulent être
soignées et donc je voudrais rappeler
aussi que 80% du personnel des soins
palliatifs ne souhaitent pas le suicide
assister tout comme plus de 80% des
personnes en EHPAD est-ce que tenir
compte donc de des avis de ce personnel
qui sont qui sont confrontés tous les
jours aux fin de vie et vous avez dit
aussi que en fin de vie la le suicide
assisté
donc une mort solidaire et non et non
pas une mort solitaire alors là je vais
vous dire quand même que ça me paraît
tout à fait anormal puisque les les
soins palliatifs c'est effectivement une
mort solidaire et tout à fait
accompagnée enfin j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure quelqu'un qui a dit que
lorsqu'il y avait une mort cérébrale et
bien on était obligé de continuer des
directives anticipées non c'est faux le
le Conseil le Conseil d'État l'a dit
lorsque on est en mort cérébrale
c'est-à-dire que la respiration est
mécanique est bien après une décision
collégiale ça a été
dit d'ailleurs l'an dernier on peut
arrêter effectivement
on peut arrêter même s'il y a des
directives anticipées avant et enfin
dernier ma dernière question
si vous voulez pourquoi
aller aussi directement au suicide
assisté ou à l'euthanasie pourquoi pas
dans un premier temps développer des
soins palliatifs
préalablement à toute décision
merci Madame la présente moi d'abord je
voulais vous remercier pour pour
l'intelligence du travail que vous avez
produit et
j'allais dire d'abord parce que
jusqu'ici jusqu'à votre travail la
parole des citoyens c'était les sondages
qu'on nous débiter un après l'autre et
qui disait 90% des gens sont pour
l'euthanasie 85%, 92% des gens qui sont
pour autant nazis et là vous avez vous
êtes entré dans la complexité de la
question et on voit qu'en entrant dans
la complexité la question d'abord vous
avez bien différencié le système assisté
l'euthanasie dans l'aide activaware etc
et là en fait moi plutôt que les
chiffres dont j'ai pas grand chose à
faire j'ai vu vos votes successives
qui traduisent en fait la complexité de
la question et je suis convaincu qu'en
regardant les intitulés des votes que en
fonction d'ailleurs des conditionnalités
des contextes que vous posez il y a des
votes qui bougeraient si les conditions
n'était pas rempli si si etc dans un
sens ou dans l'autre peut-être donc moi
je trouve que c'est extrêmement sain que
il y a eu ce travail à collectif citoyen
que vous ayez mené et qui vient nous
rapporter à nous parlementaires qui
devront voter l'évolution éventuelle de
la loi le fruit de votre travail et donc
je vais pas du tout entrer dans le débat
sur le fond c'est parce que je souhaite
faire aujourd'hui mais moi j'ai une
question à vous poser c'est
la phase parlementaire qui s'ouvre elle
va être très longue puisque on sera pas
vous savez d'habitude le gouvernement
impose toujours la procédure accélérée
c'est à dire faut bâcler les textes et
discuter très rapidement et là pour une
fois pour une fois c'est très rare il va
respecter la procédure normale ça veut
dire qu'on est parti allez au minimum
pour un an et plutôt 18 mois de
procédures parlementaires c'est 2024 pas
avant en tout cas l'ablissement à la
pression
est-ce que vous estimez que votre rôle
il est terminé complètement la saisie
est terminée vous avez rendu votre avis
ou est-ce que vous estimez que au cours
de cette procédure parlementaire vous
pouvez avoir encore un rôle
d'interaction avec nous avec les députés
avec les sénateurs pour voilà échanger
pour je le dis parce que les membres de
la Convention citoyenne sur le climat on
a vu qu'il y avait une sorte de
frustration alors après on a vu des
appels de de collective de membres
certains sont présentés aux élections
d'ailleurs c'est une autre question mais
on a vu que des groupes de membres de la
Convention citoyenne on continuait à
produire en fait derrière voilà mais je
trouve que c'est imparfait je trouve que
la richesse de votre processus c'est
d'avoir tenu tout le monde quel que soit
les avis dans le processus jusqu'à terme
et ça c'est aussi un beau succès voilà
comment vous voyez la suite
alors Raymond de penser toutes les
questions vous notez si vous avez des
vraiment de penser mon rouge
oui alors merci pour ce travail parce
que effectivement moi je trouve que
parce que si on devait qualifier le
rapport c'est vraiment qu'il n'est pas
maniqué
vouloir changer la loi c'est pas
forcément progressiste il y a souvent on
change la
loi on a des exemples récents et c'est
pas progressif c'est tout à fait
agressif et donc
je veux dire les progressistes c'est pas
ceux qui veulent changer la loi enfin
forcément c'est en toute état de cause
moi j'ai lu le rapport et je l'ai trouvé
tout à fait représentatif de ce qu'adieu
être votre débat quant à la question
posée la question posée elle a été
ouverte par le comité éthique enfin je
veux dire c'est un petit peu eux qui ont
ouvert la question et
ils ont alors c'est pas pour ça qu'ils
l'ont ouvert mais
de fait ils ont répondu à une demande
sociale très forte d'ouvrir la question
enfin bon alors moi ce que par rapport
je veux pas on n'est pas là pour donner
notre comment est-ce que on se met dans
les quatre catégories moi j'en avais
délicate ou mettons trois qu'importe
moi j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
évalué enfin bon comme ça dans vos
discussions formelles ou informelles le
bouger de vous positions parce que tout
le monde de fait c'est pas que ça soit
les chiffres que donner Bernard mais
tout le monde de fait a été c'est un
débat qui qui est là depuis longtemps a
été amené conduit à réfléchir quand même
un petit peu à ce qui serait sa position
et vous est-ce que vous avez pu échanger
là-dessus sur le bouger de vos positions
et ce si je dis ça c'est par rapport
aussi à ce que disait Bernard
c'est-à-dire que nous on va rentrer dans
un long tunnel parlementaire et comment
le travail que vous avez fait qui est en
fin de compte un débat éclairé comme
l'avait été la convention citoyenne sur
le climat et comment à partir d'un d'un
débat éclairé la position la position
qui qui en vient comment nous enfin
comment la société doit accompagner
enfin quels sont les débats encore à
poursuivre à mener et de qualité et pas
de façon manichéenne pour que les
Français fassent alors pas en façon
accélérée pendant accélérer que ça parce
qu'ils ont un an pour le faire mais le
même chemin le même cheminement que vous
avez fait avec ce qui est le cœur de ma
question à savoir le bouger des
positions voilà
je voulais dire aussi que bon enfin
c'est une parenthèse j'ai dit que
j'allais pas donner mais le groupe
parlementaire dont je faisais partie qui
est allée en Suisse pas du tout vécu que
vous avez eu et ça sera très intéressant
d'en discuter parce que vraiment la
Suisse voilà avec les soignants avec les
équipes qui le font avec les y compris
il y avait des représentants religieux
enfin il y avait rien d'effrayant dans
dans l'exemple je remercie
chacun et Madame Toury conclura Florence
la salade
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
vais poser des questions assez courtes
sur le recrutement vous avez vous avez
expliqué comment vous étiez recruté je
voulais savoir quel est l'âge moyen je
voudrais savoir si parmi vous vous êtes
nombreux à avoir eu dans votre entourage
ou professionnellement une expérience de
fin de vie pénible ou pas et je voulais
savoir comment comment sont compensés
les journées que vous passez est-ce que
vous êtes indemnisé
voilà je sais c'est très simplement ce
que je voulais demander
sont très pratiques aux pratiques
Véronique Guillotin et Martin lévrier
plusieurs moments des lignes rouges je
vais rajouter derrière les conditions
non remplies et vous l'avez évoqué aussi
alors dans les lignes rouges je les ai
pas entendu donc est-ce qu'il y a
quelques lignes rouges que vous avez mis
comme ne pouvant pas du coup est-ce que
la loi ne pourrait pas évoluer si ces
lignes rouges n'étaient pas remplies et
dans les lignes rouges ou en tout cas
les conditions de remplir vous avez
évoqué les budgets les moyens les kittés
territoriales etc tout ce que l'on ne
sait pas faire aujourd'hui en matière de
santé simple et de soins palliatifs
comment pensez-vous évaluer ça avant de
vous prononcer puisque vous avez
considéré que c'était pas possible de
mettre en place un système qui était
plus inégalitaire que ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui et un deuxième sujet c'est
l'encadrement médical si j'ai bien
compris donc est-ce que l'encadrement
médical vous avez considéré qu'il était
nécessaire que ce soit fait dans un
encadrement médical que la mort active
soit mise dans un encadrement médical le
système de l'Oregon pas à proprement
parler d'un encadrement médical strict
puisque les gens sont à la maison donc
est-ce que c'est pour vous un rejet a
priori donc de ce système de type Oregon
et puis je rentrerai pas non plus dans
dans le débat il y a plein de choses où
je peux être d'accord d'autres non mais
c'est pas je crois que c'est pas le
sujet en tout cas je pense que ça
éclaire sur effectivement globalement
les divers questions que l'on se pose
tous et chacun dans notre parlementaire
individuel donc voilà je pense que le
débat continuera dérouler mais c'est les
deux questions que j'aurais voulu poser
parce que j'avais elle était inscrite je
suis désolé Martin mais Martin lévrier
conclura conclura les questions merci
madame la Présidente merci mesdames et
messieurs pour vos pour vos témoignages
moi je voudrais plus vous poser des
questions sur la forme que sur le fond
on disait que pour le fond on aura
sûrement beaucoup d'auditions beaucoup
de discussions et des temps de réflexion
pour se positionner je voulais savoir ce
que vous retenez de cette expérience de
toutes ces heures que vous avez passé
ensemble à réfléchir à discuter comment
est-ce que vous avez géré les désaccords
et ce que vous savez dans quelle
proportion les avis des membres de la
Convention ont pu évoluer au cours des
travaux réalisés et puis plus
spécifiquement à madame Claire Toury le
bilan que vous tirez de ces quatre mois
et surtout est-ce que vous avez
identifié des pistes d'amélioration en
vue des potentiels prochaine conventions
sur d'autres sujets et est-ce que vous
pensez que tous les sujets peuvent faire
l'objet de telles conventions merci
merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement un député européen qui est de
ma ville mais pas de maline politique
a battu en brèche vos auditions en
disant qu'elles étaient parfaitement
orientées et que il n'y avait pas eu
donc de vrais débats que tout était
orienté que moi j'aimerais bien savoir
quoi vous m'expliquer un peu comment ont
été choisis justement pour parce qu'il y
a pas eu de contradiction sur ce sujet
je trouve que c'est toujours embêtant un
peu nous expliquer comment vous avez je
n'ai pas entendu répète rappelez-moi
parce que j'étais un peu étonné de ça
donc un peu expliqué comment ont été
choisis les personnes que vous avez
auditionnées une autre question si la
loi caisse Leonetti avait été
parfaitement appliquée est-ce que vous
pensez que votre approche de la question
de la première ministre aurait été la
même ou pas
une autre question si le Parlement
modifie tout ou grande partie de vos
préconisations comment réagirez-vous et
puis toute dernière question beaucoup
plus personnelle et un peu pour sourire
en fait ce que vous avez fait vous avez
découvert ce que nous faisons en 80% du
temps est-ce que ça vous a donné envie
de passer en politique ou pas du tout
merci
merci madame la Présidente de me
redonner la parole juste je voulais
réagir à votre affirmation madame
Berriot si vous le permettez tout à
l'heure quand vous avez dit que la mort
naturelle n'existe pas
comment
qualifiez-vous la mort de quelqu'un qui
décède brutalement d'un infarctus passif
et que pensez-vous de l'affirmation de
nos voisins belges qui disent que
quelqu'un qui meurt par l'euthanasie a
une mort naturelle
en clair quel est votre définition de la
demande naturelle s'il vous plaît pour
terminer à l'un Dufour et là on va
arrêter ensuite Alain Dufour
merci
mesdames merci Monsieur pour ce rapport
pour juste rapidement une question une
observation
aujourd'hui c'est la convention
citoyenne Conseil national de la
refondation c'est la méthode Macron tout
le monde le sait alors ma première
question et le Parlement dans tout ça et
sur le sur le fond comment garantir
surtout la réelle application des soins
palliatifs dans les EHPAD et je pense
que à mon niveau je crois que la c'est
la loi Leonetti me convient parfaitement
et c'est l'été appliqué dans son
ensemble résoudrait beaucoup de
problèmes et on n'aurait pas à se poser
ces questions aujourd'hui
on commence allez monsieur je va Neuvic
vous allez démarrer une petite
conclusion
de même
beaucoup de questions
concernant le elle est dans l'ordre
concernant notre présentation ici à nous
tous vous avez remarqué on est quatre
participants il y a un contre il y a 2
pour un troisième je sais pas
et moi j'estime que alors sans étiquette
mais avec opinion faudra expliquer par
ailleurs moi j'estime que nous-mêmes les
contre on a galéré pour se retrouver ici
mon on est arrivé et puis finalement je
pense aussi que je représente beaucoup
de courants d'opinion on a beaucoup de
subtilités on aurait pu être 4 entre des
conservateurs qui peut-être étaient
contre la loi pour des questions de
principes et des gens qui ont évolué et
qui ont été à l'écoute des médecins qui
pour finalement se positionner contre
l'évolution de la loi alors qu'a priori
ils auraient été plutôt on va dire entre
guillemets progressiste donc moi oui je
suis tout seul mais ça me va très bien
et j'ai la consolation de ma camarade
par ailleurs par ailleurs alors
l'évolution vous avez parlé de
l'évolution des groupes nous étions un
groupe assez peu nombreux au départ je
pense les contres et nous n'avons cessé
de croître on est un groupe on est les
contre sont été 39% certainement de le
citoyens ce qui est pas négligeable plus
nombreux je pense que certains de mes
camarades
par ailleurs l'évolution elle a été le
résultat de l'écoute des médecins pour
la plupart de de des contre donc le fait
d'avoir écouté les médecins d'avoir
entendu leurs arguments et leur les
médecins n'ont pas donné de position
quand ils nous parlait mais ça a
convaincu beaucoup de citoyens de
s'attacher aux soins palliatifs avant
d'envisager quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc moi je dirais puisque vous ferez la
même chose que nous et ce sera pareil à
l'Assemblée nationale être à l'écoute
des médecins c'est toujours une bonne
chose
ensuite
merci Monsieur
les lignes rouges et les conditions pour
ce qui est des lignes rouges on avait
clairement je pense l'autre Convention
nationale à rejeté l'idée d'ouvrir les
nouveaux droits aux mineurs
alors ça ça a été vraiment une ligne
rouge assez
clairement et très majoritaire
pour ce qui est des conditions
prérequises à l'ouverture de nouveaux
droits il aurait effectivement
l'application pleine et entière de la
loi classique donc de grâce avant
d'envisager quoi que ce soit jouer au
jeu de la loi classe Leonetti et
appliquons là sur tout le territoire
je termine il reste encore quelques
questions intéressantes
elles étaient toutes intéressantes bien
sûr ce que nous retenons de cette
expérience notre expérience je remercie
claire Touri le 16e les organisateurs je
pense je parle en mon nom mais aussi au
nom de beaucoup de citoyens que j'ai
rencontrés ça nous a fait un peu plus
aimer la France ça nous a fait un peu
plus aimer notre système démocratique ça
nous a fait un peu plus aimer le fait de
s'impliquer dans la société et je
voudrais
sincèrement très chaleureusement et
presque l'alarme à l'oeil remercier le
CESU et l'initiative qui nous a réuni
voilà
sur la question plus délicate de
l'orientation des débats
vous savez
le problème vient de la formulation des
questions et souvent de l'ordre
d'exposition nous n'avons jamais eu
on a essayé de faire voter pour savoir
combien de personnes étaient contre le
tanazi ce vote ne nous a pas été ouvert
non
et puis
il est vrai que la formulation des
questions nous n'avions pas la main
dessus je le regrette et donc je pense
que c'est une chose constructive
constructive pardon pour améliorer le
modèle de démocratie participative il y
aurait beaucoup pas dire que ce soit le
groupe des comptes qui s'est senti
frustré très souvent que le groupe des
pauvres qui aurait voulu aussi
participer au niveau de la formulation
des questions et de l'ordre des votes
alors il y a toute une réflexion à faire
nous l'avons commencé nous à les ex on
s'appelle déjà les ex conventionnels on
a commencé cette réflexion elle est
intéressante j'espère qu'elle sera utile
à de futurs conventions et à tous ceux
qui représentent le peuple français
merci merci à tous
je fais vite alors je voulais répondre
quand même quelques questions notamment
dans le désordre monsieur Chassin je
crois qui posait différentes questions
et notamment vous évoquez le chiffre de
80% des soignants
d'où sort ce chiffre qui quel est le
sondage qu'il n'est soin palliatifs vous
vous basez sur l'enquête de la safap ok
d'accord
qui est une enquête ou en fait il y a eu
135 soignants finalement qui ont dit
qu'il ne voulait pas
travailler là-dessus qui ne voulait pas
si la loi était modifiée continuer à
travailler dans les soins palliatifs
je vous raconte sur une anecdote parce
qu'elle me semble bien illustré le truc
en fait on parle beaucoup des médecins
mais je pense que c'est bien de parler
des médecins et des soignants moi j'ai
été invité à la FEA
j'ai été invitée à la Fiat qui est donc
une Fédération Hospitalière privée il y
avait un sondage où on voyait qu'il y
avait une grande dichotomie entre la
position des médecins et la position des
des soignants et où en fait tout le
personnel qui était au chevet du patient
était plus proche de l'aide de
l'ouverture de l'aide active à mourir
que les médecins en tout cas c'est ce
qui était dans le sondage après on en
fait ce qu'on en veut je pense que ça
c'est important aussi de voir d'où l'on
parle à chaque fois donc 80% des
soignants je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être voir ce qu'il en est je pense
que en terme vous parliez de la dérive
nous ce qu'on propose pour éviter des
dérives c'est ce qu'on a essayé
d'expliquer avec Antonin c'est en fait
le parcours c'est à dire qu'évidemment
pour nous nous voyons pas la l'ouverture
de l'aide active à mourir comme étant
une option comme on prendrait je ne sais
pas n'importe quelle option sur doctolib
c'est vraiment dans le cadre d'un
parcours avec un accompagnement médical
très sérieux d'une équipe
pluridisciplinaire voire
interdisciplinaire pour voir si vraiment
cette personne peut suivre et accéder à
cette aide active à mourir vous disiez
aussi les personnes malades changent
mais même les personnes en fait qui sont
en bonne santé on sait bien que les
directives anticipées finalement ça ça
nous a été ça nous a été dit moult fois
les directives anticipées il faut les
refaire refaire refaire parce que quand
on est en bonne santé à un moment donné
on évolue et vous le disiez tout à fait
justement quand on a des pathologies qui
commencent à venir finalement ce qui
nous semblait insupportable
insupportable et donc on change au fil
de l'eau donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important ce que nous en dit les
équipes soignantes aussi
c'est que en fait ce qu'il faut surtout
voir c'est le milieu c'est les personnes
de confiance la famille etc qui nous
permet ensuite d'avoir une une opinion
et de savoir si la personne veut
toujours veut toujours cette chose là
je pense
c'était votre question aussi madame sur
ce que ça nous a apporté moi ce que ça
m'a beaucoup apporté c'est que
finalement on voit bien que si on donne
un collectif quel qu'il soit de
l'information de la formation il est
tout à fait capable de produire un
rapport que moi j'estime de qualité vous
nous en avez remercié on vous remercie
pour ça et on pense qu'on peut vraiment
être un allié dans le Parlement
contrairement à monsieur qui n'est pas
là mais j'aurais voulu lui dire que on
s'inscrit pas du tout à la place des
parlementaires nous on pense qu'on peut
être vraiment un appui au parlementaire
et notamment parce que les conventions
citoyennes il y en a de par le monde ça
n'est pas comme il l'a dit la méthode
des conventions citoyennes il en existe
il y en a eu plus de 400 qui ont été
faites dans des pays aussi improbables
que le Pakistan le Bangladesh etc c'est
que ça doit être possible quand même de
faire ce genre de choses sur la mort
naturelle alors je précise en fait ce
que je voulais dire par là je m'appuyais
sur des propos qui sont des propos de
Martine Lombard que vous avez peut-être
accueilli ici qui est une juriste qui a
écrit un livre remarquable qui s'appelle
l'ultime demande et puis les
interventions de Véronique Fournier
souvent qui sont donc vous la connaissez
la personne qui a mis au point qui a
créé le Centre des tiques cliniques de
Cochin qui disait que finalement avec le
fait que nous avons des médicaments
depuis que nous sommes petits etc mais
en fait ça on peut plus dire maintenant
qu'on est sur des morts naturels
oui oui j'ai compris mais je vous dis
d'où ça vient on peut ne pas être
d'accord pas de problème
alors les Belges
je peux pas vous dire sur ce truc là
oui oui mais
la mort est naturel c'est que quand le
médecin le médecin légiste coche il fait
ça pour pas qu'il y ait eu une enquête
en assassinat homicide etc je veux pas
de faire autre chose
c'est-à-dire cette formulation qui
peut-être vous a choqué c'était l'idée
de dire que surtout on peut pas avoir
enfin on a des une médecine encore une
fois qui est formidable en France
vraiment avec qui permet de soigner
beaucoup de choses mais au moment où
cette médecine notre système de santé
extrêmement cure dans le curatif au
moment où cette médecine ne peut plus
rien pour nous je trouve que c'est un
abandon de soins auprès du patient et
donc du coup cette histoire de nous dire
tout le temps il faut maintenant que la
personne meurt naturellement n'a pas de
sens je vais le formuler comme ça plutôt
peut-être ce sera plus précis par
rapport
oui oui donc j'arrête là j'arrête là et
si je dis une dernière chose si je peux
me permettre oui là sur la mort
solidaire et solitaire en fait je pense
que nous ce qu'on a vraiment réussi à
faire dans la convention citoyenne je
prends un petit peu de hauteur pour pas
répondre comme ça c'est qu'on n'a pas
opposé les deux et que la loi classe
Léonetti qui serait appliquée à 100% ne
répond toujours pas aux problématiques
des personnes qui ne sont pas avec un
pronostic vital engagé à court terme ça
ne répond pas à ça donc nous on est on
sera avec les parlementaires pour
travailler sur les soins palliatifs et
aussi pour l'ouverture de l'aide active
à mourir merci
merci Nathalie pour répondre à la
première intervention de Madame Cohen je
crois
tout d'abord merci pour pour vos mots je
ne peux corrigendre vos propos cette
convention citoyenne c'est basé sur le
respect l'écoute de tout un chacun nous
sommes sur un sujet très sensible qui
est la fin de vie évidemment que nous
sommes tous liés à ça nous avons tous
été confrontés à une situation de fin de
vie d'un proche de dadami enfin c'est
très compliqué à gérer et forcément
l'émotion se mêle à ce mail à la
réflexion on ne peut pas le nier c'est
pourquoi nous avons été très bien
accompagnés aux ses œufs c'est pourquoi
il y avait des coachs des psy qui était
là aussi pour accompagner les citoyens
qui souffraient de de reparler de
situation de morts de proches etc donc
c'était assez compliqué il y a trois
volets importants comme vous l'avez
signifié qui ont été mis en avant par
Madame Agnès Firmin le Baudot le
développement des soins palliatifs
l'ouverture de l'aide active à mourir et
la protection des personnes et des
droits des personnes nous rejoignons
cela pour le ceux qui sont pro ou aide
par nos ouverture de la taxi va mourir
la ligne rouge monsieur le lien lévrier
pardon je suis désolé les lois en fait
n'évolueront pas sans accompagnement
et une évolution
des budgets alloués à la santé et pour
les 100 palliatifs et pour la formation
et pour arrêter avec cette inégalité
territoriale donc par exemple les soins
palliatifs et les lois la pardon la loi
n'évolera pas la ligne rouge c'est aussi
le fait qu'il faut un parcours
d'accompagnement sans se parcours
d'accompagnement il n'y a pas de mourir
qui devrait être ouverte en fait parce
que nous devons accompagner nous devons
protéger les personnes nous revenons
donc sur protection des personnes des
droits des personnes
il y a eu énormément de votes nous avons
énormément travaillé je tiens à appuyer
le fait que nous avons pu faire
retravailler les votes que nous avons pu
nous impliquer dans le processus
démocratique
oseze je vais vous donner un exemple un
jour j'étais tout à fait en désaccord
avec une méthode j'ai été le dire j'ai
été voir les animateurs les
facilitateurs nous avons tout remis en
place 5 heures de travail en plus nous
avons terminé à 23h ce jour-là le CESU
était à notre écoute la transparence et
la traçabilité était de mise c'était
magnifique vous aviez des dossiers mais
remplis avec tout le processus de
traçabilité et c'est là dessus que je
souhaite appuyer très fortement
en ce qui concerne l'encadrement médical
oui nous devons
procéder à l'aide activé à mourir
encadrer encadré par des soignants
cadrés par des médecins pas de Kill pile
à la maison comme en Oregon nous sommes
contre cela trop de dérives nous sommes
d'accord concernant les dérives bon
toute progression sociale toute pardon
excusez-moi toute évolution sociale tout
est l'évolution de la loi en fait se
confrontent aux dérives pour reprendre
l'IVG nous pourrons prendre l'abolition
de la peine de mort à chaque fois chaque
évolution de la société nous sommes
confrontés à cette crainte de la dérive
mais je suis persuadé que l'intelligence
collective l'intelligence humaine
l'intelligence sociétale et dans les
législations permettent d'empêcher ces
dérives nous n'allons pas tomber dans
une dystopie parce que nous aurons les
dativa mourir
aucun des citoyens n'est pour une
ouverture de l'aide active à mourir sans
condition vous pouvez penser que ce que
je représente c'est sans condition mais
ça ne l'est pas il y a des conditions il
y a un parcours d'accompagnement il y a
une épouse du passant il y a une
révocabilité de la demande c'est
toujours possible de revenir en arrière
il n'y aura pas de dérive à mes yeux
tout cela est soumis à réflexion
mais c'était la crainte d'une nouvelle
évolution la crainte d'une évolution
dans la loi de l'autorisation de l'IVG
de l'abolition de la peine de la police
de la peine de mort que tout le monde
allait procéder à l'iviger ce n'est pas
le cas tout le monde va pas se jeter
vers le thanazi on parle bien de
personnes en souffrance nous n'allons
pas nous retrouver avec des gens qui
vont foncer tête baissée dans la mort
les gens ne veulent pas mourir en fait
personne ne veut réellement mourir et
attendez certains veulent mourir
certains veulent mourir certains sont
suicidaires et justement d'ouvrir un
parcours d'accompagnement d'ouvrir
l'écoute de faire rentrer les gens dans
ce parcours encadré par des spécialistes
encadrés par des psychiatres mais c'est
leur donner une chance c'est leur donner
une porte de sortie et quelque part une
idée que c'est possible sans forcément
vouloir le faire au Québec il y a un
grand pourcentage de personnes qui sont
allés chercher cette kill qui ne l'ont
finalement pas prise
tout le même cela veut dire beaucoup de
choses je vais je continue je ne vais
pas trop traumater excusez-moi
donc pour revenir sur l'intelligence
collective les conventions citoyennes
c'est vraiment ça que ça nous a apporté
et c'est la confiance en nous la
confiance en cette intelligence nous
pouvons faire beaucoup de choses
ensemble et remettre le citoyen au cœur
du processus c'est lui permettre d'avoir
un nouveau confiance dans les process de
démocratie dans les institutions car il
y a vous le savez une peur du citoyen
une crainte une enfin forcément on voit
les contestations sociales et lui
redonner la parole lui redonner la
parole et vraiment impactant et c'est ce
que nous avons ressenti et nous
remercions le 16e pour cette pour cette
grande
découverte cette grande expérience le
fait de se rapprocher de la démocratie
pour ma part j'ai toujours été un petit
peu rebelle bah au final je me retrouve
tout à fait en lien avec ce qui s'est
passé je suis heureux d'avoir partagé à
participer à ce process je reprends des
études en transition écologique et
solidaire j'aimerais aller vers la
politique vers l'intelligence collective
pour vous répondre monsieur
et désolé pour la pour les roses sur le
nom donc voilà je voulais vraiment vous
remercier de vous avoir écouté et je
vais laisser la parole à Madame Clotilde
Guibert qui vous appuiera d'autres
points
alors je vais répondre brièvement parce
que mes amis ont déjà répondu à pas mal
de questions mais oui je complète donc
pour nous il y a véritablement l'intérêt
à développer les conventions citoyennes
pour vous aider par le mentir parce que
ça permet une réflexion finalement de la
société tout entière on se rend compte
que on a des citoyens extrêmement
engagés qui s'intéressent au sujet parce
qu'on a tous un vécu différent on a des
sensibilités différentes donc il est
important de les écouter de les entendre
de les comprendre aussi donc pour nous
ça a été extrêmement important ça nous a
permis de nous souder tout en nous
respectant avec différentes nuances on
est tombé d'accord à l'unanimité sur le
développement des soins palliatifs
partout et pour tous ça c'est indéniable
maintenant et je vais reprendre
également les termes de la commission
temporaire de la fin de vie qui disait
que il était également en plus de la
nécessité de développer des soins
objectifs partout en France d'octroyer
des droits à ceux qui le demandent tout
en respectant les droits des autres ça
c'était important maintenant vous nous
demandiez si nous avions poursuivi nos
missions en tant que membre de la
Convention citoyenne et je dois vous
dire que nous avons fondé deux
associations l'association des 184 et
une autre association
des 184 également voilà il y a une
association avec des membres extrêmement
investis impliqués également et ça
permet un avis participatif avec des
membres disponibles pour répondre aux
différentes demandes et dans toutes les
régions avoir également des échanges
avec les députés voyez on ne s'arrête
pas on s'investit et les scènes et les
sénateurs pardonnez-moi je ne vous
oublie pas je ne vous oublie pas nous
avons également continuer
nous avons également continué avec
différentes interventions des
conférences débats également dans
différentes structures et notamment des
hôpitaux
j'insiste nous avons également
particulièrement travailler sur la
journée des droits des patients les
Journées Européennes les journées des
droits en santé où on a pu mettre en
place différents stands par exemple dans
les hôpitaux de l'AP-HP pour informer
promouvoir sensibiliser au droit des
patients notamment sur les directives
anticipées personne de confiance refuse
soin arrêt des thérapeutiques
obstinations déraisonnable parce qu'il
nous apparaît important que la
population française et notamment les
patients parce que ils sont au cœur
de leur prise en charge et bien
connaissent leurs droits donc moi je
vais parler en mon nom personnel ce que
je retiens de cette expérience c'est
quelque chose de très riche humainement
et émotionnellement qu'on n'oubliera
jamais qu'on n'oubliera jamais et j'ai
je suis particulièrement étonnée du
respect que nous avons eu les uns envers
les autres contrairement à certains
politiques qui n'ont pas forcément les
capacités de s'entendre nous nous sommes
respectés nous avons
respecté les nuances et les avis et les
sensibilités de chacun voilà je vous
remercie infiniment
alors on se calme un peu il reste encore
quelques minutes
on se calme un peu je pense qu'on
travaille aussi dans le respect l'image
donnée par l'Assemblée nationale n'est
pas forcément celle du Sénat
oui enfin Madame écoutez vous êtes ici
dans une commission si votre clé
sénateurs se comportement vous avez tout
le loisir de ne pas conclure non c'est
pas ce que je voulais dire non je
voulais vous remercier je voulais
remercier les quatre citoyens qui sont
venus parce qu'ils travaillent voilà et
c'est important pour eux de venir porter
cette parole parce que il y a un travail
remarquable qui a été conduit pendant
quatre mois et donc voilà moi je voulais
vous remercier pour ça je voulais vous
remercier aussi pour votre écoute et
pour vos questions le je crois que pour
répondre à la question pratique donc il
y a bien une indemnité qui est versée
c'est 84 euros net par jour et puis
ensuite il y a une compensation pour
perte de revenus pour les gens qui
travaillent et qui du coup posent des
jours de congés donc ça c'est 11 euros
de l'heure et à ça ça ajoute à ça
s'ajoute pardon un défraiement complet
donc déplacement hébergement frais de
garde d'enfant etc enfin c'est très
important que ces dispositifs ne soient
pas excluant et qui est pas de comment
dire d'inégalité sociale par dessus
voilà donc ça ça c'est un élément
important après pour vous répondre
j'avoue qu'il y a beaucoup de questions
j'essaie de vous répondre rapidement le
le moi ce que je retiens quand même
c'est qu'on peut pas sortir indifférente
c'est un exercice démocratique comme
celui-ci et que ce soit sur la fin de
vie ou sur d'autres sujets mais sur la
fin de vie c'est assez parlant quand on
arrive on donne un bout de soi-même et
on prend un bout des autres et ça c'est
quelque chose de profondément marquant
alors pour les citoyens ça c'est clair
vous l'avez vécu mais même pour nous en
tant que comité de gouvernance en tant
qu'equipe organisatrice on était là tout
le temps et c'est ça moi ça m'a donné
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir en
notre démocratie parce que voilà enfin
vous faites un travail remarquable mais
on sait que les Françaises les Français
ont une défiance quand même assez forte
vis-à-vis des institutions et il me
semble que travailler à des outils pour
les associés davantage pour que la
construction de la décision publique
elle n'appartiennent pas uniquement aux
élus mais qu'elle puisse être aussi
alimenter par des citoyens des citoyens
à qui on donne des outils à un moment
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour répondre à votre question sur le
travail parlementaire à suivre vous
verrez si vous souhaitez auditionner ou
non des citoyens des citoyennes mais
vous avez quand même 184 citoyens qui
ont bossé 37 jours 27 jours sur la fin
de vie ils ont un niveau d'expertise
aujourd'hui qui a un niveau d'expertise
citoyen mais qui est très au-dessus que
la plupart des Françaises des Français
et c'est bien normal parce qu'a priori
on n'est pas tous des spécialistes de la
fin de vie donc ça je pense que c'était
important de le dire donc ce que je
retiens pour vous répondre c'est ça et
un autre élément que je retiens c'est
que il faut pas non plus faut pas être
dans un discours trop angéliste en fait
tout ça c'est énormément de travail
c'est énormément de travail vraiment que
ce soit pour les citoyens qu'on parte
qui ont participé ou pour les personnes
qui ont organisé cette convention c'est
un énorme travail de mettre en mouvement
tous ces gens et de s'assurer que les
choses se passent au mieux alors je on a
des humains en face de nous et le
principe c'est que la démocratie c'est
une matière organique on peut essayer de
tout anticiper on anticipera jamais tout
et donc il y a parfois des réactions
qu'on avait pas anticipées des
commentaires des interventions
extérieures intérieures et donc ça ça
nécessite voilà de se réajuster en
permanence mais je crois que quand on
intègre cet élément là et vous donner là
et qu'on est prêt à travailler beaucoup
pour vous répondre je pense que oui la
plupart des sujets peuvent être portés
et traités dans le cadre de ses
conventions après mon avis à moi à titre
personnel c'est qu'il y a deux types de
sujets qui peuvent faire l'objet enfin
qui peuvent être particulièrement
intéressants de traiter dans le cas
d'une convention soit des sujets qui
n'ont pas encore été défricher et pour
lesquels on a envie de voilà de de
tester d'interroger les citoyens des
citoyens dans un cadre un peu spécial
soit des sujets sur lesquels il y a des
débats depuis très très très très
longtemps et dans lesquels les espaces
classiques et pour lesquels pardon les
espaces classiques ne permettent pas
d'avancer alors c'est pas le bon terme
mais voilà je trouve que c'est
intéressant et pour moi faire une
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
c'est une forme de courage politique
d'une certaine manière parce que c'est
accepté à un moment de faire un pas de
côté et de demander à des gens qui ne
représentent que même mais qui vont
travailler de manière exigeante et
remarquable d'aider les décideurs à
construire une réponse politique
exigeante après on en pense qu'on en
pense ça si vous avez bien le droit de
penser ce que vous pensez évidemment
mais je trouve que de ce point là c'est
vraiment intéressant à dire et par
rapport aux critiques de certains élus
moi je franchement je veux bien tout
entendre que ce dispositif soit
perfectible qui est des erreurs qui
étaient formulées je réponds à Monsieur
par rapport voilà qui est des erreurs
qui étaient formulées qui a un point
d'amélioration enfin qui est des pistes
d'amélioration c'est une c'est évident
par contre vraiment sous-entendre que
les citoyens ont été manipulés ça je
peux pas le laisser dire parce que c'est
faux vraiment c'est faux d'une part et
d'autre part je trouve que c'est pas
rendre justice à l'intelligence des gens
et dernier point quand même parce qu'on
a quand même fait on a vérifié quand
vous regardez les auditionnez etc le la
proportion des points de vue a été
respectée et les soignants qui disent
qu'ils n'ont pas été assez entendus 3/5
des auditions c'est c'était des
soignants et donc du coup je veux bien
je trouve ça indispensable d'entendre la
parole médicale il y a pas il y a pas de
sujet mais c'est une convention
citoyenne pour poser un débat de société
et donc voilà je veux juste te dire ça
mais je vous remercie je sais pas si
j'ai répondu à tout mais en en tout cas
je vous remercie pour pour votre écoute
merci merci à tous les cinq vous êtes
prêté à cette à cet exercice et en effet
lorsque le débat viendra bien évidemment
le rapport de la convention ce sera
examiné avec attention mais je rappelle
aussi que pour beaucoup parmi nous nous
organisons aussi dans nos départements
alors pas avec décoration mais des
réunions publiques sur le sujet la
députée Nicole du brechira de mon
département on a fait plusieurs sur sa
circonscription moi j'en ferai une enfin
fin septembre aussi on est aussi à
l'écoute bien évidemment de ceux qui
sont les plus proches de nous sur le
terrain merci beaucoup à tous les cinq
merci beaucoup